alexis poulain bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver pour débuter la semaine sur la
matinale de rtl france alors emmanuel
macron la vue fait tout pour éviter un
confinement va-t-il être gagnant dans
cette stratégie du risque selon vous
alors c'est quelque chose qui reste à
voir selon son expression reporter dans
lors d'un conseil de défense même si le
chemin est étroit il faut l'emprunter on
a l'impression que le premier de cordée
prend des risques
et là il pourrait faire dévisser toute
la corde et celle d'angers une stratégie
illisible compliqué et les français en
ont marre on a vu hier soir
la punition un des automobilistes gérald
darmanin qui a fait bloquer le péage du
bus relais pour mettre des amendes aux
automobilistes qu'ils rentraient à 18h
et qui ont été bloqués dans plus de 400
kilomètres de bouchons provoqués par les
contrôles de la police donc c'est
scandaleux
ça n'a rien à voir avec des mesures
sanitaires on est là purement dans la
punition dans le montrer de le pouvoir
qu'on peut avoir c'est assez assez grave
plusieurs choses qui font que m l'alma
kron a choisi d'éviter le confinement
d'abord je crois qu'il y a l'état des
chiffres qui ne sont pas si
catastrophiques donc on continue
d'attendre et de voir le fait de ne pas
vouloir fermer les écoles et puis des
voisins comme l'italie qui commence à
assouplir les mesures les bars les
restaurants et les musées qui ouvre
l'espagne également chypre d'autres pays
qui choisissent davantage de souplesse
deuxième raison pour ne pas confiner la
lassitude des français et le risque
massif d'une désobéissance civile comme
on le voit en autriche en allemagne au
danemark où là ça pourrait vraiment
dégénéré et avoir un refus massif de
l'autorité et la mg macron se
retrouveraient ridiculisé par une
désobéissance massive face à ces mesures
autoritaires et non pas sanitaires et
puis la dernière raison pour ne pas
confiné c'est le prix de ce confinement
on voit très bien que dans cette
histoire de coronavirus depuis mars le
quoi qu'il en coûte est devenu ça va
sans doute nous coûter très cher et je
crois qu'il est d'ores et déjà enterré
et on passe on passe à la presse à
savoir qu'est ce qui va se passer quand
de nombreuses pme une sur deux parfois
ne pourront pas rembourser le prêt
d'état et donc les failles systémiques
qui risque d'en arriver alors voilà un
peu les raisons qui font qu'aujourd'hui
à venelles macro hésitent à confiner et
on peut le comprendre
alexis qu'attendre alors cette semaine
alors cette semaine plusieurs scénarios
possibles soit on reste sur ce plateau
les chiffres continuent comme ils sont
là et on va continuer avec des mesures
d'ajustement de contrôle comme on a vu
alors avec aussi le risque d'une fronde
parce que si tous les soirs à 18h en
bloc périphériques pour mettre des pv
aux automobilistes ça ne va pas passer
c'est pareil si on met des amendes aux
franciliens qui sont en train de faire
des courses dans les supermarchés à
partir de 18 heures là non plus ce n'est
pas des mesures qui sont acceptables
donc à voir quelles vont être là les
marges de manoeuvre ensuite si les
chiffres sont mauvais et bien on va sans
doute avoir droit à un conseil de
défense mercredi
et puis peut-être une allocution soient
des modèles macron soit du premier
ministre qui nous diront bon écoutez on
a tout fait pour l'éviter mais on ne va
pas pouvoir alors on va confiné et ça
tombe bien c'est les vacances scolaires
ça évitera du coup de fermer les écoles
et de confiner ce confinement serré a
évoqué par gabriela talent qui durerait
pendant les mois de vacances les
semaines pardon de vacances scolaires et
puis sans doute de nouvelles mesures à
attendre
et ça c'est beaucoup de risques toujours
est il que ces mesures qui sont des
mesures de restriction des libertés qui
ne sont pas des mesures sanitaires ne
montre pas beaucoup d'effet dans la
luttre contre la la la la pandémie ce
virus et on a un problème dont on parle
peu finalement c'est la campagne de
vaccination qui marque un coup d'arrêt
alors vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
marge de manoeuvre de l'exécutif qu'elle
était en réalité cette marge de
manoeuvre
alors il en a très peu on le voit il ya
déjà le nombre guillot au niveau
européen avec les big pharmas les labos
astrazeneca et d'autres sur le fait que
les big pharma ne veulent pas livrer
davantage où sont coincés dans la
livraison parce qu'elles n'ont pas
augmenté leur capacité de production
donc là on est coincé avec les doses
question aussi de logistique
aujourd'hui on se pose beaucoup de
questions puisque des centaines de
milliers de doses de vaccins dorment
dans les supers congélateur et ne sont
pas distribués alors est ce que là c'est
une stratégie pour éviter justement de
pénurie de deuxième injection ou
préparer encore une baisse de livraisons
de la part des labos problème aussi avec
ses fameux vaccin sur l'efficacité de
ces vaccins
voit notamment l'autorité de santé
allemande qui critiquent astrazeneca en
disant qu' il n'y a aucune preuve sur
l'efficacité de ce vaccin pour les plus
de 65 ans et qui préfère ne pas vacciner
mais plus de 65 ans et d'autres pays qui
vont vacciner uniquement jusqu'à 55 ans
avec ce nouveau vaccin donc manque de
candidats vaccins qui arrivent sur le
marché manque de doses campagne de
vaccination qui finalement s'arrête on
ne peut toujours pas prendre de
rendez-vous quand on souhaite se faire
vacciner c'est extrêmement compliqué
voilà un peu les risques mais quelque
chose d'incompréhensible dans cette
stratégie de long terme il faut savoir
qu'en mars 2020 on avait 2500 lits en
réanimation en ile de france
aujourd'hui on est à 1700 lit c'est à
dire que pendant cette pandémie pendant
tous ces mois où on a continué à
empêcher les français de vie de sortir
on a continué de fermer des lits en
réanimation et ça c'est incompréhensible
donc au delà de la livraison des vaccins
la fermeture de lits est
incompréhensible
et puis que faire avec la recherche sur
les traitements au delà des vaccins on a
peut-être des traitements et des labos
français notamment à limoges ou ailleurs
sont en train de travailler sur des
traitements aux anticorps ou autres
parce qu'on ne peut pas tout mettre nos
oeufs dans le même panier et croire que
le vaccin sera miraculeux et permettra
de mettre le virus derrière nous donc
très peu de marge de manoeuvre une
semaine sans doute encore en dents de
scie avec soufflé le chaud et le froid
en fonction des chiffres et de l'état de
l'opinion publique ont reçu ça de très
près sur rt france et voir comment
l'exécutif va encore nous mener par le
bout du nez pour cette semaine
merci beaucoup alexis pour votre
décryptage c'était l'édito de la
matinale d'alexis poulain